hey guys it's Wednesday I'm Dan and Jess
isn't here because a Wolverine like back
is acting up but really I just think
she's old lady masquerading as a 26 year
old anyway this is guess what news
[Music]
first up Dragonball Fighters that sweet
fighting game that looks exactly like
the cartoon finally has a release date
along with some new characters
Komatsu translated an article from the
latest issue of v-jump magazine that
revealed new characters details on the
story mode and a Japanese release date
of February 1st 2018 the two new
characters joining the roster are Napa
and captain ginyu Napa can summon
Cybermen in battle while captain ginyu
can call in the ginyu force and his body
change to swap characters and HP with
his opponent it was also revealed the
game's original story will feature
Android 21 and a resurrected Android 16
the story mode will apparently see Z
fighters falling one by one and players
will be linked to different characters
throughout the campaign you'll be free
to focus on earning XP rescuing allies
learning skills and more including the
option to deepen bonds with characters
which will reward you with the chance to
overhear private conversations no other
regions release date has been announced
as yet aside from early 2018 but
hopefully we in the West don't have to
wait too long after Feb 1st if you want
to check out the full list of revealed
characters so far head on over to
GameSpot Microsoft has revealed a bunch
of stuff about halo sorry it's not a new
one but the ones that do exist are about
to get a lot prettier developer 343
industries today revealed that halo wars
2 will be receiving a patch to unlock
visual upgrades for the Xbox one X the
dev also wants to bring the Master Chief
collection forward and modernize many of
the game systems as part of this 343
will launch the flighting program in
spring 2018 that allows players to test
new patches Halo Wars 2 is also getting
support for the Xbox Arena system which
allows players to create tournaments as
well as cross play between PC and Xbox
one sometime in late October we already
knew that halo 5 was getting an Xbox 1x
patch with 343 has revealed that it's
part of the larger overtime program that
will bring a bunch of new features
content and support to the game
including the oddball game type and
weapon balance changes in November
remember 1 collector's editions just had
crazy stuff like night vision goggles
well Gran Turismo sport has one that has
a car like a real card if you can
totally buy ok so there was a 368
thousand dollar version of dying light
which included a real-life bunker so
this isn't totally unexplored terrain
but Gran Turismo sport on ps4 could
indeed be picked up in a bundle that
also includes a limited edition 2018
Mazda mx-5
complete with Gran Turismo and ps4 logos
because why not the bundle also includes
a ps4 pro a PS VR headset a Thrustmaster
TGT steering wheel which is just a
horrifying name and a bigger a p1 racing
chair a bravia 4k HDR TV 12 months of
PlayStation Plus and the game only one
of these bundles went on sale for a cool
forty six thousand six hundred dollars
and it was already snapped up by a car
collector so I guess that's the whole
story and it was just a waste of your
time I'm sorry Gran Turismo sport is out
today though so that's something that's
everything I have here did I enjoy the
rest of your day just and I won't be
here tomorrow on Friday you're gonna
have two very special guest hosts but we
will be back Monday so we hope to see
them what nothing like doing this on
your own to highlight the absurdity of
it about halo today sorry it's not a new
one but all four Assassin's Creed
origins was a little bit ridiculous Gran
Turismo sport is here to smash it with
the supercar come drive one edition